Three,
two, one...
This is Sugar Rush.
Four teams of brilliant bakers
compete against each other
and the clock
over three rounds of competition.
Why do I feel like time speeds up in here?
Whatever speed you're at, double it.
Round one, cupcakes.
That is quite a presentation.
Don't have too much fun 'cause
you need to win $10,000.
Okay.
And round two, confections.
Oh, that was off the chain.
I think they just hit the nail
on the head with this theme.
This is, like, an Instagrammers dream.
Third and final round, cakes.
It's cake time.
We have no time.
This is a horse race.
I have never made a wedding cake
in three hours.
Oh, this part makes me so nervous.
My hands are shaking trying
to put these decorations on the cake.
What happened?
Uh...
-We're not bothering--
-Stop bothering him!
Feeling the pressure, feeling the heat?
Aren't you guys done yet over there?
Now it's a competition for real.
Are you okay?
You're a mess.
I'm feeling very judged.
The team going home today
is going to be...
This is nerve-racking.
With the long pause.
Come on!